kansas city i can't wait to get to your
wonderful town i'll be there january
20th through the 22nd get your tickets
for those dates and all dates at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media happy new year to all y'all out
there i hope you had a a great holiday
season and the best to all of you this
year all right
um
come out see me on tour tickets
available ryan sickler.com we're still
running out there
please subscribe to the youtube as
always i mentioned and uh the patreon
the patreon ain't going anywhere y'all
it is the honeydew with you all
it's five bucks a month
and that's right we're keeping it five
bucks a month right now still and you
get the honeydew a day early ad free at
no additional cost all right you sign up
for a year you get over a month free all
right uh and if you or someone you know
has a story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together you know what we do over here
y'all we highlight these low lights
we find a little light in the darkness
these are the stories behind the
storytellers i'm very excited to kick
off the new year with uh a guest
returning here please welcome back
andrew santino welcome back to the honey
dude i missed that arsenio when he used
to do it
that's that cleveland dog pound i know i
um thank you for kicking uh the 20 22
year off with us by the way god bless
we're out here 2022 we made it baby god
bless we made it
we're alive we made it through premise
so far
so good we'll see we'll see what o'mara
kron does too um
plug everything you'd like please all
right 2022 uh i'm um over the hump of
halfway point on my tour um and this
this year i've got uh
are you ready for this yep albany
foxwoods
um
dc atlanta chicago february 5th chicago
theater that's my home coming yeah what
a great [ __ ] time i mean even i get
love in chicago they are a very
supportive city they really are then i
do kansas city st louis vancouver
seattle portland and i end this beach in
vegas
vegas at the win march 26th and i need
people to come out because that's how i
feed my family okay
your family of just me and her
she's expensive dude women are expensive
hey man they eat they eat soup
like that on that low-key i know when we
bought when we went out and had pizza
remember that after we went to have
pizza and your girl wanted another slice
and you were like
i was like no one and done one and done
i was like maybe i'll give you a half of
this when i'm not eating right here get
the crust you get the crust for this
other one
i have a lot to talk to you about but um
give it to me i love you a few things i
want to talk you i want to talk to you
about
touring right now because you said
you've got some frustrations you just
told me you were depressed about
something that and i want to talk about
that oh yeah it's very
uh pertinent to what we do and then i
want to ask you some family [ __ ] so okay
you tell me well
the touring thing that i talked pretty
candidly about
the tough thing is like
you know
i think things that people don't know
but the public doesn't know is like once
you start selling tickets
and clubs and then you get these offers
to do theaters and you're there is no
handbook we're all kind of green so
they're like oh then you can play
theaters and you're like okay so i'll
try that
but when you play clubs it's partly
their
internal promotion partly because people
know the club and then they follow you
as well so it's like three things are
hitting for the theaters the theaters
don't do any promotion
barely and if they do no one's following
a theater on instagram let's be honest
i've been bitching about the clubs
aren't promoting anything either i know
dude but the theaters literally do zero
i haven't go look at the clubs
on their facebook you can get nine likes
i know but at least the club has a
history right so true people who are
locals know right but with theaters it's
you you you you dude i mean it's you
it's you
yeah live nation ain't doing it take a
mastermind on it yeah you know they do
little things in there but but they're
taken oh yeah
we ain't doing before we're taking
that's what yeah
we ain't doing
uh that's a convenience fee right for
what's inconvenient for me yeah stop
charging me eleven dollars on a nine
dollar ticket
[Laughter]
they they do they
so doing the theaters has been tough
because this is my first time learning
and nobody wants to talk about this
stuff and stand up that it that it's
difficult emotionally if your ego
you know tell me about it because it
because it's like i don't i know who i
am i'm not i know what i i know i have a
good fan base but like
you have to do all this work and then
your teams your agents or managers or
all these people like they they want to
push more dates on you and add more
shows and your your worry grows because
you're like can i do that am i how do i
promote it now what do i have to do
online to like grow that audience um
louis puts up a date you sell you know
those guys do it's just different i'm in
this kind of middle ground where it's
like
i can sell good tickets but also adding
shows is sketchy and you might not sell
out the other one or you might just sell
really well for two shows or three shows
but you have to put in all this work and
there's anxiety that goes into it and
then when people tell you in the
business they're like just let it go
just you know
you know but you can't because you work
so hard to get to get to this place
you're not just gonna sit back and be
like whatever happens happens i mean i
wish i had that mentality i don't think
most comics do because we started at the
bottom to get here took so long but also
these people that are telling us these
things have 401ks yeah yeah they said
that that was [ __ ] paid sick and
vacation days they have pensions
probably they've got [ __ ] all kinds
of [ __ ] that we don't have it's easy to
tell somebody that has no net
when you're sitting in one right to just
it's all right don't worry about it yeah
no you're fine no that you're rowing
away my boat's on fire
get to the back man weigh it up
the big flames aren't coming for a while
no you know what i compare it to is like
when and i love and i love
jim carrey but when i was working for
him on that show uh showtime and i'm
dying up here yeah one one time he said
to me um
you know he was talking about becoming
more minimalistic
and
i joked with eric griffin afterwards i
was like you know only only only super
super rich people can talk like that
when people talk like when they go you
just gotta get rid of possession dude
you just gotta be free man you just
gotta let go let god you're like you
can't say that the guy that has three
jobs
he can't let go and like god because god
will kill him you know what i mean
so i
and no disrespect to jim it was just you
have to and and jim came from zero too
he was broke when he started he was poor
and then he earned all this money but
only with money comes that kind of
perspective about how things are if you
if you weren't telling me to let go uh
let god when you were broke right then
don't don't tell me that [ __ ] when
you're a gazillion that's what i'm
saying yeah so so it i compared to the
same thing of like when they say don't
worry about it or or you're doing fine
it's not going to ease your your anxiety
and your depression i've been super
candid about my mental health on our
show on on my show with bob and my
personal show
that like you know i have anxiety i have
severe depression i've been diagnosed
i've gone through waves of it over the
years it goes way up it goes way down
what's your
anxiety what brings your anxiety outside
of the outside of obviously making a
living we all have in our careers the
anxiety of life sure
what what outside of professional i
think a lot of times i i feel like um
you know you get scared if you're doing
all the all the other right things am i
being a good enough friend
husband
family member
community like am i do am i
am i being more than just my job because
this job is all-consuming i just told
you my schedule is absurd i mean our
schedules get absurd i have four or five
things every day and then shows at night
and then it used to be i could grab
coffee with someone now it's impossible
yeah
it's it's just gotten harder because
you're filling up your plate because
you're like well i need to do all these
things to get this other thing done but
then i have anxiety at night like well
am i even doing enough
as a human or am i just operating as a
business machine now because i have to
keep up you know you have to hold this
thing up it's kind of like when you were
a kid
and you used to hear about guys that
like we're keeping up with the joneses
you know what i mean and then you find
out he's been stealing from the company
and he's upside down
we're 20 grand in on the in-ground oh
yeah we talk about it that's what i mean
it's just you that fear of like oh you
have to hold up all these things
and for me those things i'm holding up
are outside of the business it's like
am i being a good enough
family member friend partner am i doing
these things right and it's really hard
on you am i calling enough people just
to say what's up to check in to try to
schedule a good dinner
it's super difficult because your
schedule gets overwhelmed we don't what
you said before the show i don't you
know cutting the grass it's like uh
you know i
i we don't have the luxury of just being
like oh man sunday's a down day for me
it's like what are you doing on sunday
i'm gonna watch the ravens and after
that i'm gonna [ __ ]
put my
headphones on i'ma listen to the after
uh the the post game wrapper game wrap
up for the app in baltimore yeah 1057
the fan the fan
yeah
cut the grass
i want to do that but i want to be that
i want to do that sometimes and
sometimes i do get to live that life
and i'm not by no means because i know
the audience something you know like
champagne problems like cry me a river
but like
no matter who you are no matter what
you're earning or what your job is we
all have our own little issues do you
know what i mean yeah well what we do i
say it all the time it's a very selfish
thing it's just by nature it is a
selfish profession to go in and do this
because it's all about you and it has to
be because once you do get to another
level now you've got to maintain and
provide for your family whatever so
i say it all the time we it's not it's
we're still comedians but this is our
family business like it's not just i go
on stage anymore the 80s
it is the podcast it is the patreons it
is the video the sketches the merch
sketches the promos the you know photos
though we are we are
all in one shot it's we all this is our
family right and everybody out there i
know they say champagne whatever they've
got their family businesses and all of
us had adversity the last almost two
years with the shutdown so a lot of
people hustlers like us and people out
there like you guys have their foot on
the [ __ ] gas and
we have coffee
that's why i have too much evidence it's
my 14th coffee
i've spent money no no no i want my i
want that coffee baby
that's what i'm drinking i'm getting the
last drops of that no that's all you hit
in that corner no but you know what it
was oh yeah it was a corner of a round
cup i saw you get it though that's that
corner of the round cup no you know what
it is though for real um
it's like you you just
there are two ways to look at it right
some people are good at just like
letting go and
figuring it out as it goes
i was never that guy and i don't think
i'll ever be that guy so well go back to
your background your your dad's not
around in and out of prison you're
raised by a single mom single mom until
she met my stepfather who became my who
who became my my father in a formidable
sense you know became like you know
taught me how to ride a bike and throw a
ball and swing a fist and you know what
i mean like yeah but you've got a
mindset of i've got to do this yeah but
it was also because it was kind of like
um
not that i had to grow up fast but i
guess it was like living in the city
with my mom you just had to
you had to figure it out a little bit it
was like girl you know the phrase i grow
up i say that sometimes in a mean way
when somebody says i'm like grow up like
get over it it's you you can't control
it it's gone it's over it already
happened
and
that comes from kind of my mom's
mentality she was kind of a tough she
was tough love in a good way but she was
also like you got to get over it it's
it's done it's already happening you're
going to complain about it all day no
it's not i mean dude we joked about this
at thanksgiving
this is how different this is how
different the 80s were
uh because the i lived close enough to
school in the city where the bus
wouldn't get me because it's in like a
mile and a half was the radius or
something that but my mother didn't want
me to walk because it was like it was
the city and it's also like a little kid
by himself and she couldn't because she
was working full-time and couldn't
afford to hire somebody
so there was this dude who was like a
retired him and his wife they drove this
old station wagon the old crown vic
woody
and they picked up kids from our
neighborhood oh my god this sounds
right right right no no it doesn't get
bad it doesn't get bad it doesn't get
bad it doesn't imagine the sales pitcher
this cup will be like we'll drive your
kids to pick up your kids we need to
pick up all seven of your kids dude
there would be like six and we'd be in
the old in those old early uber right
now but people remember people remember
if you remember those old like the
station wagon crown vics the first of
all the bed of those things was like an
f450 it was it was 55 feet dude it was a
yacht it was a yacht carpeted yacht
and if you couldn't get if you didn't
get picked up in time or your your route
was because he changed all the time
depending on the traffic you wouldn't
get the bench seat the the you know the
bench back seat which was you could fit
14 little kids in that bench seat no
one's got a seat belt on right and you
would have to get in the backpack if you
didn't get a bench seat how many kids
are getting in the backpack
[Laughter]
just rolling around
i mean just
and and if you were really unlucky you
had to sit on a wheel well you know what
i mean
it was too hot because the metal was
frying it dude we would be bouncing
around you'd hit your head on those
windows at least four or five times on
the way home because it's not fast you
smack your head on the side
he's just some neighbor just some guy
just some guy from the neighborhood let
me take you to school i mean i did it
for two years two years he used to pick
me up in his car oh yeah bro oh yeah
and you know what's so funny is and
sometimes he'd be late you know because
this guy just lived his life and i would
be standing in the rain outside of
school when it'd be closed i remember
standing in the rain for the home right
back
back home and i remember how mad i was
and i thought to myself i could just
walk i better just i could just walk
home but then i knew if i walked my mom
would have beat the [ __ ] out of me if i
walked
all the way home because back then
uh cabrini green was still there yeah
that's good cabrini green was like the
uh the projects the projects okay it's
not there anymore
robert taylor was the most famous
projects but cabrini green were pretty
pretty famous and now
it's like right next to a kind of a nice
area now it's their condos and you know
what i mean but back then it was still
there so it was kind of a sketch if i
was walking around there it's like
no one's gonna really [ __ ] with a little
kid but it's just the idea that's like
how little you were like eight nine i
was
seven that's my daughter's age right now
i can't imagine letting her let her walk
on a city a mile
yeah come on man but back then yeah but
we did i did get to walk around like
there was a white hand pantry uh down
the block and around the corner that i
used to go there and steal donuts they
had long john donuts that was my
favorite but i was so low to the ground
i could sneak in and walk out and the
dude would never see me you know behind
the counter because i just what was he
gonna say but white hen was like um
7-eleven it's the same kind of thing
but she would let me go walk to the
white hen or walk to little spots around
or the grocery store
but
in retrospect it was funny because now
you you wouldn't you would never like
never never not only would you never if
you did yeah you'd be arrested yeah you
go to prison you would yeah absolutely
it would have run around there's no
doubt about that but that but anyway so
so cut going back to her her tough love
was always a part of my family's thing
and so because of that i think i had to
figure out a lot of stuff on my own take
the risk this whole career was is a risk
whether or not people like it or to hear
that but like it's a sketchy risk i sat
in bed when i first moved out here
sitting on a mattress literally on the
ground in a partitioned off dining room
that i talked about last time i was here
sharing a one one bathroom with four
guys
you know and i was scared i couldn't
make 385 rent i was so scared i was so
scared that
i'm not kidding i was like if i sell
enough blood or sperm or body parts
maybe like maybe i can pay rent again
i've looked into it i talked about it
here you've been you've been there we've
all been there where you're like
donating sperm sperm yeah i've looked
into plasma but plasma was deep i looked
in the sperm and my grandmom you know
she's alive at the time and she was very
upset she's a catholic woman telling me
that this these are still my children
these are still my children it's not
some load i'm shooting into a [ __ ]
sock these are my kids
you know it is
so
um
but what i realized when i actually sat
down and i started making phone calls
and there's no internet i'm talking to
all these nurses these people and what i
learned was that you're only allowed to
donate two samples and a certain mile
radius
because
although it might be
improbable it's possible that those two
could be male female and then mate and
live in that same way how many people do
you know from high school stay in the
same area i mean almost and then have
children and unknown
be incest wow isn't that crazy
so you're telling me i only get two
loads of maryland i mean i didn't think
i'd have to go cross-country i was about
to drop 20 in this area yeah but
maryland's not that big bro you got to
move you got to move you know that's
like texas is great you spur your sperm
map of texas you can keep moving around
houston one weekend
next week
i thought about it dude and i got scared
and i thought well this is a bad idea
this is going to come back to haunt me
but but anyway so that anxiety is what i
still carry today
as the man i am today i don't think i'll
ever get rid of it i'd like to think one
day it will money doesn't solve that
problem no
time i think will start to heal it as i
get more comfortable with
what i'm creating in my career and also
i need to learn how to step away
vacation santino is the best version my
lady always says that to me she's like
dude you're the best on vacation i don't
check my phone i'm not on the internet i
don't give a [ __ ] there's no schedule we
don't plan [ __ ] we just do it we just
walk around till we're like this looks
like a cool place to chill we'll go hang
out somewhere we don't make grandiose
plans we literally go to the place that
we want to go on vacation and we just
figure it out as we go and if we can do
it we'll do it if not we won't and then
that's it and that's what i love because
i can't do that here here it's like noon
to one 1 30 to 2 2 30 to 4 meet with
this guy call call stand up stand up
stand up go to bed wake up all over
again
so that the anxiety
is fueled from
not feeling like i um
and not do enough do not far enough are
enough of a human outside of my job
which is that's where the anxiety comes
from and the depression comes from
you know you said you were diagnosed
what does that mean and and what how did
you get diagnosed i think i had a pretty
you know when i was in college i think i
spoke about this but i had i had um
on here i think i had uh
i had ocular migraines that i still get
sometimes i go blind in my left eye for
how long i don't remember i mean you may
have very well sometimes 30 minutes
sometimes
up to an hour and a half i mean are you
[ __ ] yourself thinking you're gonna
be well when it first happened i did and
so i had like a break i mean i almost
had like a psychotic break so i went to
i had a severe panic attack i passed out
i couldn't breathe damn i went to the er
because i thought i was going blind i
thought something was wrong with my
brain
i did mris and cat scans and blood work
and
you know and my my girlfriend at the
time god bless her she did take me
everywhere you know she was doing
everything and then i left her in
arizona when i moved
i could see that [ __ ] oh god
no we had no business being together she
was she was she was she had to fly free
i had to go to la and fail but anyway
but but she used to take me she would
take me to the er and all that stuff and
um
yeah after all this blood work got done
and then i i went to the
i went to see a few different doctors
and they were like well what this is a
combination of kind of like a not a
psychotic break but i had an emotional
breakdown because it might the the
pressure of ending school and if i was
going to leave and where i was going to
move and i was going to start my career
and i just piled everything on my
shoulders and let it sit and sit and
then it kind of all cracked at the same
time so the ocular migraines were a
product of high amounts of stress
terrible diet no sleep and it was all
like the snapping point my body just
gave up
and
it was kind of a sign of like
me not taking care of myself at all and
on top i was just hiding depression
through
not sleeping and partying and
trying to forget about everything and
not caring and pretending like i didn't
have an attachment to my future
and then that was
eye-opening for me to be like you you
have these i had these heavy waves of
emotion where i would get super super
high and really really really low
almost bipolar and so
what are you feeling at your lowest like
um not you know this is not funny not
suicidal no no it's not funny to joke
about like because i know that's a real
thing for people but like
i i never that never came into my mind
even a little bit like i thought that
was crazy even when i was at my lowest
but as i was at my lowest i would think
about
this is a really funny turn of phrase
ending at all but not my life ending
whatever i'm doing being like i'm gonna
disappear
i'm almost like suicide social suicide i
see was like i'll leave everyone i won't
talk to anybody ever again and i'll
start something else somewhere else what
would you do
i mean i know you've put thought in yeah
back then it's not enough i'll bet no
but back then i used to just and and
sometimes it enters my brain today of
like
wouldn't it be wild to j this is
disgusting it's almost sociopathic to be
like wouldn't it be wild to just leave
and not tell anybody friends and family
and just go get a labor job in the
middle of nowhere shave my head you know
what i mean and go go live in the middle
of nowhere nothing and just work a job
with my hands go to work and go back to
my life yeah santino's roofing
i'm telling you i'm in omaha yeah he is
man in the middle of nowhere yeah i just
want to live in the middle of nowhere
and don't talk to anybody and just
that would be that was my getaway my
getaway was like what if i just left and
it's not like i'm leaving for another
family or another thing i just wanted to
i wanted to just shed all the pressure
and the that's how i i think some people
do feel that way that they're like what
if i could just get rid of all this [ __ ]
and just disappear
and not die but just
try to start over again or something
because the pressure gets insane so
that's what i would feel when i was at
my lowest was like how do i
how do i get how do i escape escape yeah
how do i escape i don't want to end my
life
but i just want to get out of this one i
want to get out of this one yeah it's
wild which is funny that you it's funny
because like uh i always used to say i'm
too selfish to kill myself you know how
they say people that kill themselves are
super selfish i said i'm so selfish i
won't kill myself because i want to know
what happens you know i mean you're such
a selfish self-indulgent brat that i'm
like i want to know where this thing
ends up i don't want to take care of my
i don't want to do that now
but
now i don't want to do it there's a
there is a chance
but you know we talked about i talked
about in the barber the other day i said
i was we were listening to i know i'm
i'm jumping all over the place but
that's how my brain is but
future islands is a great bed you know
who that is it's a great band dude you
want to see a great performance future
islands did a performance on david
letterman right at the end of
letterman's run and my god you could
always tell when dave liked a band when
he went over there and he was like oh
wow like he would get hell he had the
foo fighters like what every night he
would blows it out yeah you could just
feel when he liked somebody when he
didn't like or when he didn't care for
it or was whatever he was like hey give
it to this guy how about that that's
great
watch this performance of future islands
uh on letterman it will blow your mind
he's so
animated and the the singer so he's
beating his chest and letterman was
blown away and it kind of
catapulted their these guys anyway i'm
at the barber and he's got it on in the
background
i was like man the passion in this guy's
songs and they're so
um
they're like so heartfelt and gut
wrenching a little bit like you can feel
the sadness in there i love that [ __ ] oh
it was so real but then i said we're
just sitting there it was really quiet
it was just me and him and the whole
barber shop
and i said
i wonder if
him playing those songs every weekend
makes him sad because in the same way
that comics people don't understand is
like making people laugh sometimes can
kind of get you in a down place because
you're exuding all this energy to make
other people feel feel feel feel feel
and sometimes you're not feeling much
because you're so focused on making
other people feel
and especially with music
if you're not connected to music you're
probably playing bad music but if you're
connected it's probably good [ __ ]
music oh yeah no matter no matter what
category in the grocery store yeah yeah
the bag of peas
but i think i was like i wonder if that
really hurt sometimes gets him down and
that because we talked about how chris
cornell
committed suicide i was in that hotel a
while is that i was in detroit
interviewing golden tate wait at the
same time no no i was there the same way
i was there i was there we were there we
were there holy [ __ ] we were there
because i was interviewing golden tate
for a show i did called um here's the
rub it was like this character-driven
show where i played this russian it's a
whole thing it was for yahoo sports it
was fun how about that goes back to get
him russia i get him it goes that's
exactly right it goes all the way to the
feet so but we were there and i said
about when cornell killed himself at
that at that hotel i was like did that
dude
play such a long career of passionate
heart-wrenching gut-wrenching music that
it finally caught up to him like
and i can't it's interesting i mean i i
don't know if that's the case well think
about i i do this five minute journal
every morning and it's just an exercise
of positivity and you're writing
positive things i'm grateful for this
i'm i am this i mean in the night time
these great things happen what could i
have done better and it trained your
brain to think glass for me half full
yeah not half empty right so
if you're always writing something
positive and it can shift your brain
that way it would make sense to me that
if every day you wrote that you hated
your life you hated yourself you hated
your career that that that would find
it's gonna go yeah at some point i mean
that makes sense to me and it's not what
i don't know if i'm not all of his songs
were that but i mean a lot of his stuff
was heart heart-wrenching it was go it
was very like his guts were out do you
know what i mean
it just it was so real his version of
nothing compares to oh my god
that's
unreal it's unreal he i just he so
anyway so we were talking about that and
i thought
you can let it get to you it really does
get to you because when i had you know
my little like break
you really understood your body was just
done dealing with your anxiety and your
stress so i'm learning how to manage it
better exercising definitely helps me
personally
getting up in the morning and just going
to do it it's great something about it
has changed the way i
and also as you get older i i can't eat
the cheeseburger right before bed
anymore those days are gone because you
feel way worse in the morning and i see
it i feel it but going to the gym will
make me mentally and physically feel
better so i've been doing
that's been my balance to battle anxiety
and stress and then also taking time to
just go away i take drives at night
which is that's nice yeah i do it all
the time it's kind of weird at first she
was
you know she was adverse to it she's
like where are you going were you
running away and i was like i just like
to sit in the car
with no music on and just think and i
just take long drives
because i used to do it when i was a
teenager we should go for a drive all
the time nobody does it now
but i just because gas is 85 bucks a
gallon
yeah you're [ __ ] breaking the bag but
you know join the patreon so i can keep
taking them rides
[Laughter]
it's for my yeah but i do i'll take long
drives i'll go way up uh
santa clarita i'll go way out there
drive around i don't know it just gives
me a way to like escape at night because
sometimes sitting in the house is like
driving has always been a freedom i love
it dude i love it so much i hate being a
passenger yeah no i hate it i hate it i
don't want to be in your car i want to
be in my car and i want to drive i want
to be driving yeah wherever i want to go
so that kind of helps me but i found
little tricks to help me out but that's
not to say dude i don't get i get
there's bad days there's bad weeks
you know luckily i don't have bad months
i don't go through like big chunks like
that but i go through
consecutive days consecutive weeks and
then i'll slowly start to turn out of it
and what's usually a shift that helps
you
hmm
you know talking to family helps a lot
talking to my mom
perspective and then also um
unfortunately or maybe fortunately but
work like a lot of times getting up on
stage when i'm in a bad way
does help me kind of get to a better
balance like see there's a community
that loves you and appreciates you fans
and and our friends
and then there's like it's like it
like rejiggs rejiggers your your insides
like hey man don't you know people
value you you value them you value this
world you put work into this thing it's
a there is a a mutual
you know
there's a reciprocation in this thing
that you've built so go be in it so
sometimes being in it helps me get away
from being
deep and in my head and
stressed out and sad and
you know
although i like to escape from work but
sometimes work is the thing that goes
hey
work being stand up specifically yeah
but like it just gets me back to like
you know knowing there's a community
that cares that you've built that you
love that you care about and cares about
you and that's a nice comfort to have
it's the same way that
you know people who actually enjoy their
jobs they do probably because the
community is kind of nice it's nice to
go talk to people at work it's nice to
work with clients that you get along
with that you get to joke with it it
feels the same way to us as a guy who's
in sales or a girl who's in
you know marketing or whatever the
people that whatever you're doing i i
think like when you have the community
it helps you kind of feel okay again a
little bit yeah because you know that
we're all going through [ __ ] so it's
like no one's exempt that's why i did
this show yeah you go look at everyone's
social media it's everybody's highlights
yeah and this is the [ __ ] total
opposite of that page right this is this
is this is this
yeah
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements you are not alone the weight
of debt can be crippling but upstart can
help you on your path to financial
freedom upstart is the fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan and it's all online so whether
you're paying off high credit cards
whether you're consolidating high
interest debt or you're funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date so rather than
looking at your credit score alone
upstart considers other factors like
your income your current employment and
your credit history to find you a
smarter rate for your loan you can check
your rate without impacting your credit
score in minutes for loans between a
thousand all the way up to fifty
thousand dollars you can even receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com honeydew
that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com honeydew athletic greens the
health and wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
simple look it's my favorite new thing
every day and i've been using it for a
while now i look i don't get to eat
right all the time i don't and also
sometimes i choose not to so i know i
need to get my nutrients i know i need
to get my vitamins every single day i'm
using athletic greens i take a little
pouch drop it in my water boom off i go
with so many stressors in life it's
difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our bodies
the nutrients it needs to thrive ag-1 by
athletic greens the category-leading
superfood product brings comprehensive
and convenient daily nutrition to
everybody and to help each of us be at
our best they simplify the path to
better nutrition by giving you the one
thing with all the best things one tasty
scoop of ag-1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole-food-sourced
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more in one convenient daily
serving the special blend of high
quality bioavailable ingredients in a
scoop of ag-1 work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet support
your energy and focus aid with gut
health and digestion and support a
healthy immune system effectively
replacing multiple products or pills
with one healthy delicious drink it's
lifestyle friendly so whether you're
eating keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten free and it contains less than
one gram of added sugar there are no
gmos no nasty chemicals or artificial
anything while keeping it tasting good
i'm telling you it's great to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you an immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give a g one a try now let's get
back to the do you're right about um
breaking points i mean i have my own
that was crazy health for six months but
i dated a girl her name's uh libby uh
we're still really good friends this was
2000 she'll probably hear this so what's
up girl what's up girl and at the time
she's turning it up right now in the car
she's like oh my god uh-huh her uh her
brother her younger brother was born
with cancer in his eye and they had to
remove his eye at base birth and then
they gave him radiation and they didn't
realize back then that the radiation
could cause later in life problems so
he kept having problems problems
problems well this tumor kept growing
and they told him they were going to
michigan keeps coming up i'm pretty sure
it was detroit
um
they were going to some world-renowned
specialist there that that said like the
the main artery that runs into the heart
is growing over this tumor and i've got
to be able to remove that tumor from the
artery and basically everyone needs to
come here and say their goodbyes because
the odds of this are not great right
she flies
she's dealing with so much at the time
um
and then gets there and she's talking to
me on the phone
in the car with her mom they've just
left the hospital their uncle's right
behind him they're just running down the
street to get food for everybody to
bring back or some clothes or something
and i hear her say
she goes oh my head
and then i hear the phone drop and i
hear her mother start screaming her name
like like someone just pulled up and
shot her in the head
and
what i find out later is the stress and
everything hit her she had a full-on
seizure she's never had another one she
had a full-on seizure her mom's got her
son
in the hospital they say by the way he
lived uh saying he's gonna die and then
her daughter's in macarthur having a
seizure right now and this woman is
losing it and it was all
a system shutdown it was system overload
and [ __ ] this reset turn off the lights
and she's lucky she's never had a
problem again with it but it was a
one-and-done
like full-on holy [ __ ] wow i mean have
you ever had a physical thing where your
body stops
yeah when um i split from my daughter's
mom i ended up getting kidney stones and
and then they went away but then my
legs started clotting hard both legs to
when i i went to the hospital i've
talked about on the air so people here
we go but anyway i uh
it was i'm sitting in the star wars
movie a few years back 2016
and i'm rubbing my legs i can feel my
veins through my jeans i'm like what the
[ __ ] i call the hospital like you're
clotting you need to get here right now
so i drive there and they ask me because
my legs are black and blue and they're
like is someone at home hurting you and
i was like come on for real
like we have that my daughter yeah
you won't believe what she's doing and
it was just
it was crazy it was six months of them
thinking i've said it before i actually
like saying it because it's so powerful
to me um
they're like you may have leukemia you
might have lymphoma they're telling me
all these things and then they're like
we're running blood tests you have to
wait two weeks to find out if you have
cancer and i'm just like great talking
about it thanks this would be a fun tool
just gives me his personal cell phone
number and he's like if you have any
problems call me i'm like this is your
he's like yeah i said i've never been
more scared of my life he's like you
seem pretty calm like what am i gonna do
you just gave me your personal cell
phone number and i can call you on
sunday if i need to he's like yeah i go
that means you think something might
happen right like
just call me if you need me i'm like oh
my god
and then i went in
and when the lady said she wasn't
supposed to tell me she's like how are
you i'm like i'm scared to death you
know i don't know what i'm about to hear
and she's like i'm not supposed to tell
you but you're fine and i was like i
don't have cancer she's like no i was
like oh she's like how do you feel i go
i just feel like a monkey's off my back
yeah and then she said well i'm gonna
tell you something it's my job every day
to tell people in here that they have
cancer and today i got to tell you that
you didn't and i'm telling you from my
point of view go [ __ ] celebrate that
[ __ ] tonight yeah i was like i am
definitely i'm gonna do that yeah that
was awesome that's wild yeah so i ended
up with this [ __ ] blood disease that
i didn't know i had that i have what is
it called it's called factor five
lighting you made that up
[Laughter]
he forgot what it was
[Music]
you know it's called
it's called 92 85 go route hook
cowboy cowboy run
you're giving me football plays a lot it
means
five yeah five means uh you're my
blood's thick it's prone to clotting
eight factor eight i've been told is the
thin the prop people have thin blood
bleed out yeah so i have thick blood
that's prone to clotting and i'm the
[ __ ] on the plane has to wear
um my compression pants and then get up
and go
i have to wait
they're they're come oh they're just
compression they're not aware of the
socks i have to wear like pants pants
full like like if i pulled my pants off
i'd look like tio running up and down
the [ __ ] plane and running my four
way isn't it good that your blood your
blood your blood
clots faster and it's better to clot
faster than slower right but it also can
clot in my body and that clots to my
heart my brain my lungs that's that's
the worry it's not when you're cut open
and it i'm gonna bleed out it's that
inside me i'm throwing prone to throwing
clots you know what you know what prp is
you know what that is platelet-rich
plasma they use this for a myriad of is
this the spinning stuff exactly right
right plasma that's how they extract it
right so they put in a machine you can
inject in all sorts of stuff this is
lance armstrong used to do this [ __ ]
well prp is the thing that most a lot of
athletes and i agree this is what they
get in trouble for right no no no this
is totally legal this is it should be
it's your pl
going back into your body right this is
totally okay okay and and regular people
use all time for
when you get stem cell injections
sometimes like that the prp helps for
like
they'll put it for stimulation of growth
either like your hair your muscles your
back there's a million different ways
the prp helps but the platelet-rich
plasma it gets divided i did this one
time i divided the i got it done you did
yeah and what do you do and when the and
when the guy when the guy that guy when
the doctor
separated it twice he couldn't believe
how fast the blood clotted and he was
like
that's a little weird and it got me
scared of [ __ ] because like that when i
listen go get tested no no it was okay
oh okay i did get my blood tested i got
my blood tested
thereafter because i um
uh uh
because i had this other thing this
other health scare for a little while so
what are they doing for you they're
doing this nobody what he's removing
he's removing this because i wanted to i
want to see if plasma can help me okay
so
he says oh it's clogging really fast and
he shows me how fast did it how fast
it's doing that so i got really scared
so it was kind of on the heels of this
other health scare that i had that i
don't want to get into but
um
i had gone to the doctor and i told him
all about that and he ran my blood
and he ran my blood and when he came in
kind of that feeling that you had
but it but it was almost like a bit for
him because he was like you won't
believe this and i was like
i was like upside down inside and he
goes this is great blood
it's like what the [ __ ]
i was ready to beat the [ __ ] out of him
yeah he was like yeah this is great this
looks great you're doing good this is
really really good he's like we were
kind of scared that maybe because of
this health scare that i had that he's
like there was something that we were
looking for maybe he's like this is
great blood and the reason he said that
is because he says you know that how's
your diet and all stuff i said look i
like drinking alcohol
i eat like [ __ ] when i'm on the road i
haven't been sleeping that much i'm
doing the best i can
but
i'm not gonna lie i like the sauce and i
like to eat shitty foods so
i was scared he was gonna you won't
believe this you know he's like you got
[ __ ] velveeta in your veins
yeah bro you got velcroing but but when
he does that when they do that and they
give you that scare but also it kind of
turned me on to getting back to working
out again the pandemic dude i put i put
down i i was putting down
so much unhealthy [ __ ] food and booze
and being lazy and then i hurt my back i
blew my back out
it's gotta be seven months now eight
months now i have a hairline fracture in
my back damn it's fixed now i think we
think there's still a herniation on my
disc i can show you the photos that's
why how did you do that
running
just from running i used to run like
five and fall no i used to run like five
to eight miles a day and i would run to
the gym lift and then run home
and then he was saying i wasn't
stretching enough and i had an
irritation and i had a mini little
fracture from the compression of running
i was running incorrectly truly is what
it was your foot's supposed to be right
below your center of gravity right have
you ever seen you've seen when great
track runners they do that leg kick up
and it looks like they're skip skipping
when before when they're warming up
that's to try to get their foot to plant
directly below their their center core
right a lot of people try to run with
their feet out in front of them it's
incorrect your feet are supposed to be
below you by the time your body hits it
should be a cen a directly centered core
if you drove i drove a stake through my
head it should go right down through my
foot
hypothetically but i was running
probably more outward you know what i
mean i wasn't stretching enough
afterwards so i got a little herniation
and
i mean a little fracture and then my
disc herniated i'm pushing my l4 l5 and
the [ __ ] pain from that [ __ ]
was yeah that back pain unspeakable any
pain dude i was on the airplane doing
this i was rubbing my legs like you're
rubbing your legs in star wars
and the flight attendant
comes up to me and she goes are you okay
and i'm thinking she thinks i'm a meth
head and i'm just like waiting to get to
phoenix so i can jump you know hit it
again
and i'm like and i go i'm okay i'm all
right and she goes you know my husband
has it if you want me i can get you ice
and i was like oh because she could tell
she could just see by looking at it she
gave me a big bag of ice and i put it on
the arch of my back and it helped a
little bit but
dude for three months the pain for me
was
unbearable like to a degree where
i couldn't believe it it felt shocking
like i tore ligaments in my leg i've
been knocked out i've been in car
accidents i've chipped my teeth i've
broken bones my nose had been broken
three times i've had all sorts of [ __ ]
nothing was as painful as the herniation
for me because the hairline fracture was
so
oh my god dude i had a herniated disc
got [ __ ] up because they didn't train
us properly in weight training in ninth
grade and they're just telling us to go
do the squats hard as you can lift yeah
and get on your name on the wall right
here they don't care how you get it up
they don't tell you to keep your back
straight you know just go under there
and throw that weight up yeah bend down
use your back to pick up those weights
so many of us yeah but [ __ ] up back
still from high from sports sports yeah
and um
i got to a point where i was working at
e at the time and i'm out on these
shoots
and i can't [ __ ] feel my leg i can't
feel it and every night i lay in bed and
it's to the point of where i'm almost in
tears from the [ __ ] same same and i
would get in my car and i would sit and
i would just move millimeters until i
could find a sweet spot not a spot where
i'm like that feels great a spot where i
could drive without crying and wanting
to just veer into traffic and kill
myself and that person okay like i know
where you've been so my friend says he
get he got an epidural for his yeah so i
go to get this epidural right and i lay
on the bed and the doctor
shows me the needle i'm like that
[ __ ] thing he's like yeah oh bro like
two feet and then we're talking and
whatever and uh he goes okay you're done
and i laugh
and he's like what are you laughing at
i'm like come on he's like we're done i
go no you didn't even touch my body he's
like you didn't feel that i go no he's
like listen to me turn around he's like
we're done he's like you didn't feel i
go i didn't feel anything he was okay i
want you to come back in two weeks just
chill out come back in two weeks i come
back again
he does another one that one i [ __ ] i
mean man do i i can still mentally think
about it because
that medicine touched the nerve and
i don't know if you've
you ever stick your tongue on a battery
or b even worse you ever get shocked
you know i was
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we should do the electric fence we have
an electric fence near us and we touch
it but then you grab somebody yeah
you hold on to those [ __ ]
that's what it feels that's what it felt
like
man it shot like lava down my leg and i
was like oh [ __ ] but it worked i've only
had to have
i'd say in the 15 years of [ __ ] it up
i've probably had that procedure like
three times so i never got one i never
got the shot because i didn't want to go
through with it because they were like
once you start you keep doing usually
they say it's maintenance it it and it
could be but my doctor was straight up
he goes listen ryan i'm not gonna let
you do this eventually we'll figure
something else out but he's like if you
keep shooting this it'll be dust you
think it will turn it to dust right
so yeah three times that's why i don't
want to do that i don't want to start i
don't want to start i'll go with you you
i don't want to start it because then
you get hooked i want to you're not i'm
telling you i've had three in 15 years i
wouldn't i would if somebody told me
they did cocaine three times in 15 years
i would not say they're hooked
no but you need it now forever now
you're going to keep doing it i want to
get to a place where i don't need to get
stabbed i'll be need a wheelchair
eventually probably
i'm really probably going to need one
cut to this
you and me in the chairs 20 years i'm
going hard if i'm in a chair though yeah
why not i want a nice chair too i want
to i want a real nice chair give me my
spinners on them
spin me out baby
what did you say to me before the show
that made me laugh if you told you 120
years ago if you said i'm gonna go get
oh yeah you said you're getting 700 more
horses yeah you said you're gonna go
soup your car up with 250 more
horsepower yeah
and i said could you imagine if we were
in the [ __ ] old days in the fields
and you just came over to me like i'm
just gonna go get 250 more horses 250
more horses
put it on this one wagon
750 horses on this one all right you
guys ready
this is selfish so these guys are over
here with their one horse like yeah this
is selfish i gotta probably be tommy lee
on the drums with all the whips
come on let's go let's go
what a time yeah what a time to be alive
yeah i wanna go to i wanna go i'm gonna
go get a fast car for no other reason
than i
man do i love fast cars
all right let me ask you about this
because we've talked about your dad
before yeah um
how old are you now 38 38 do you want to
be a dad
yeah do you yeah you went high pitched
on me a little bit no yeah i do i do i
just think it's uh it's not up to me
it's up to the universe okay you know
what i mean are you trying
yeah okay yeah so you actively want to
be a [ __ ] yeah i do i do i just say yeah
like if it doesn't happen i i it doesn't
happen that's okay that kind of thing
and i'm not 28 anymore you know yeah
38's a different world
but
you know i've come to some semblance of
like
acceptance over like well
it's okay if not there's this weird
pressure just like this weird pressure
to get married
move in with people and be in long-term
relationships and cohabitate and create
these kind of family structural units
which i'm not saying they're good or bad
people can make their own decisions in
life but there is societal pressure also
to like
make that make a family
and so having a kid thing was always
on a back burner because i was working
like a dog
and then now it's like well i don't i do
want to do that
but there is a piece of me that says if
it doesn't happen that's also okay
um but if it does how do you feel your
anxiety or issues you feel i don't think
it would change much i mean look i i
think it would be worse no i don't think
so i i really don't that i'm not gonna
sit here and be like it's gonna make
everything better but i don't think it's
gonna make anything worse i'll say that
i'll probably be the same man that i am
you will be with or without a kid but
i'll but i'll also be
um
you know i think i'll
i'll it'll force me to get have more
involvement outside of my own [ __ ] which
i think that's a health that's what's
healthy about kids for people i always
see that like they become more of
another thing well this is the thing
you're worried about how much of a
person you are outside of comedy totally
wait do you see who you are when you
have a kid right then you become a you
you have you have a choice right you got
to become a girl so that's the health
that's the hell i mean well you have a
choice you could be a shitty person you
could just not talk to the kids right i
mean you know you have three kids in
oklahoma that you don't talk to but
we're not you know i spread them around
bro i got no it's texas texas i mean
they might they might have said that
up north it was cheaper
i got a buddy that i think has a kid in
ireland
what do you mean
we were out there together and he you
know irish catholic girls there's
fertilised mexican chicks i mean they
have kids
and we he hooked up with this girl all
night long they were hooking up and we
were young we were
20 21 maybe i mean they were both ripe
you know what i mean
and they hung out all night long i don't
know if it was more than one day that
they were hooking up but they were like
in love they were good kids you know i
mean they were like rabbits
and then we left ireland and he never
knew who this girl was never spoke to
her again but he certainly wasn't
bagging it he didn't bag it at all he
was flying free no i think he might have
a little irish kid running around we
joke about it all the time i said i bet
you dude how long ago
well look it's what i'm you know it was
18 years ago the kids got to be in
college now you can look them up you
don't know
now's the time to start researching
so you're in my room you're not really
you're my father are you what if it was
tomorrow finally pay
are you gonna pay for my college
you got away for 18 years pops pay for
my schooling
yeah i think about that all the time i'm
like
could he have been could i have been a
dad before but i was always safe before
i was in college i was so scared always
so i was so scared unless it was a
girlfriend
but i was i was always so scared well
still a girlfriend
but i knew but i knew it didn't happen
you know what i mean like that was
different at least at least if i was out
being a college kid it was like and you
never see that person again you never
know i was so scared i'm so scared and i
got and i got an std in college and i
had a condom on how the [ __ ] did you do
that it was it's a skin it's a skin rash
it wasn't it was it was like a
took up i was so scared and i didn't
know what to do and i went to the
campus doctor she laughed at me
i was like is this do you think i could
die from this
she was like what are you [ __ ] nuts
it's on your pelvis she's like shut up
she gave me like one pill and some cream
it was gone like 12 hours
she's like you're at arizona state this
is your this is the only thing you're
worried about
there's those things i think a guy came
in here with herpes on his ear you're
fine you're gonna be fine he was just
listening
tell me again baby
say it again
[Laughter]
herpes on your [ __ ] ear man
listen
she's like you never listen to me he's
like i am now
tell me baby say what you want to say
no he yeah she was she was mocking me
almost
yeah but i was
i i spent so i spent all that time
avoiding
making a baby and then now you're like
well now i have to
now i'm trying now i'm actively trying i
did too forever and then i wondered
could i
you know because i'm 40 when i did it
you got to get a 40.
i mean 40s when she got pregnant so i
was 41 when she was born she was 39.
right so that's you're kind of clear
you're getting right to the edge right
to the edge of possibilities and i was
like
all right let's go for it so we just did
one to do one
not with and we didn't know to do what
do you mean just we didn't look at apps
my friend calls it uh married people sex
we just blowing loads in each other you
know
flying and then it was get an app and
all right here's my obviously here's the
dates here's this
second time didn't work and then the
third one did and i knew when it was
because it was after larson's baby
shower and i told her i was in the
middle of the day i was like we got baby
stank on us right now this is this is
how we gotta get a bed and go
went home and day [ __ ]
come here day come here near papa why do
you call me day papa it's my it's my
favorite time i love the day get that
afternoon one hour it was like saturday
you know do you [ __ ]
do you do you like it at night or not
the preference is night my preference is
really i'm a night person i like comedy
at
night first thing in the morning give it
to me i don't mind in the morning i like
stinking ass breath yeah i like nasty
sheets i can't smell it now anyway so
that's right you're still on that you
stink you can't smell our taste still
nope
there's a smell in the air now
like i was walking yesterday
a year and a year in december i was
walking with my daughter and evan we're
walking i go what's is there garlic in
here right now she's like no that's
[ __ ] it's like pine tree that got cut
down i'm like that smells just like
dinner yeah they're nice yeah that's
like the smell so when you're eating
dinner you're still not you're not
tasting dinner at all no damn no i taste
things i'll taste chemical like i'll
take there's a taste but it's certainly
not what it tastes like what do they say
are you going to get i just say my
doctor i said to him like hey man and i
my doctor's awesome he's the one that's
gone found everything wrong and help me
with it yeah i go man i still can't
smell and he's like really i go yeah you
said that [ __ ] was gonna be like
six months or whatever i go we're coming
up on a year and he just looked at me
because yeah it's [ __ ] up
i go seriously that's all you're going
to say that's it so i don't need any med
school is it ever going to come back
he's like i don't know i'm like get the
[ __ ] out he's like well you're saying
things are happening now i go yeah he's
like so maybe something's happening i go
i don't need again i i got that yeah
dude you're the only one i know that's
lasted that long yeah it sucks i'm the
only one out of everybody i know that's
got it that's lasted this long i don't
know one other person i know people are
out there but personally i'm the only
one that's still affected with smell and
taste it's been a year in mid in well
[ __ ] in two weeks did you even get the
vaccine or did you get it while you had
the vaccine no i got it
in like december of last year and then
got vaccinated i think it was like march
the first one in april the second one
and i've been fine since but just the
smell and the taste god bro but uh so
long it's way too long i can't wait till
it comes back
for you me too it's it will i think it
will i hope so i had i pizza was the
thing i ate that brought me back a piece
really i wish i've had plenty of that i
know i've had plenty of [ __ ] feet the
joe should have did it that night sorry
are you even are you even i eat my
memory at first i ate i gained weight
because i was just like depressed or
whatever bummed
and then i was like [ __ ] this and i
dropped like 20 pounds 15 pounds i'll be
honest and then um
i just started eating normal again but
just by memory
you know i know what that [ __ ] pizza
tastes like i know what a cheeseburger
tastes like does it taste good but the
minute something tastes like i could
start to taste chemicals and food you
know what i mean like
when you i go get a chick-fil-a sandwich
i can taste that
oil and stuff in it that you can't
normally taste whoa it sucks damn it's
all good i'm alive i don't care i'm
alive yeah you're fine you're good
god bro that is so crazy a friend just
hit me up and said they got covered this
morning literally this morning i'm
supposed to do something on thursday
back to the morning you're like the [ __ ]
in the morning that's your spot [ __ ] in
the morning dude i'm [ __ ] in the
morning something about how dirty we are
in the morning you're nasty the sheets
are all [ __ ] up
and i like that our breath smells i like
that you have stinky breath i like that
you're not your sexiest i like that your
hair is all [ __ ] up i do like the
[ __ ] up hair and i just like the we
look like [ __ ] together we're like
because we're animals i like the animal
thing because when we go out to a nice
dinner and you have wine and you have a
meal
and you get home and you're and you're
like tired and swollen from being out
and talking and hanging i don't want to
[ __ ] i want to go to bed i want to [ __ ]
and then eat yeah oh okay see i can i
can [ __ ] and then talk about like a
little eight o'clock [ __ ] and then we
go get a little 9 30 that's fine yeah
but but or being out i don't want to
come home no
and everything no i'm exhausted but
first thing in the morning because it's
sloppy it's gross the only problem is if
you have a dog
you got to make sure the dog is not
around because the dog will just sit on
the bed and watch you [ __ ] you catch
a glimpse of the dog it's the worst [ __ ]
on earth because they're just like
what are you doing what are you doing to
her
that looks like it hurts it hurts
i i the dog thing drives me [ __ ] that
afternoon was a good one too on like a
saturday that's a surprise attack come
back target or something just yeah get
it don't even know it's they're getting
out of the shower seriously yeah right
now right now give it to me right now
right now look down i'm [ __ ] i'm
ready to take off you can hit the button
on this thing it's gone
sometimes sometimes uh i'm in the middle
of the night too that's even weirder if
i wake up in the middle of the night to
like piss or something sometimes i'll
nudge and be like hey
like a 2 a.m er yeah sometimes in the
dead middle of the night 2 3 in the
morning
sometimes i'll get away with it most of
the time she's like in the [ __ ] out of
here she don't they don't just sword off
well they're just dumb they're they're
over it like get out of here i'm tired
but your testosterone you know you're
actually
uh your testosterone peaks the highest
first thing in the morning so
technically men are more prone to have
sex earlier that's why we wake up with
erections
your testosterone is peaking first thing
in the morning it's when you're it's
when your testosterone levels are the
highest apparently is first thing in the
morning that's why it's harder a lot of
guys don't like to [ __ ] at night because
you're like i'm gonna go to bed i've
been working all day i'm just a night
per i've always been i mean we all are
yeah no i am i mean you have to be in
the night at night i like to work yeah
like my brain is in
firing mode instead of in
uh you know like sexy turned on mode
that doesn't get there for me at night
usually it's i'm thinking about what's
coming up or what i'm doing or where i'm
going and that clogs you know what i
mean that clogs up that part i used to
[Laughter]
do you like to smoke and then have sex i
smoke all the time anyways that doesn't
bother me but um i do like to smoke and
then have sex because my senses are
heightened yeah um i don't like it music
sounds really good i feel like the
feeling of it was really good yeah i
don't like the [ __ ] i don't drink i
don't so i'm drinking well i don't like
to drink i don't like to get drunk and
[ __ ] either that's not fun i mean maybe
when we were young it was just like a
supplement of being getting over nerves
but now as an adult sober [ __ ] i'm
out here sober [ __ ] yeah i just i
don't want anything in my body just
because i fee i feel a lot better
than spoken like a true man i don't want
anything in my body during sex
get these beads out of my ass now
don't put those beads in there
i was sleeping
nothing in my body
oh my god all right papa
daddy got it i gotta go we gotta get you
out of here right now no no no right now
we're gonna wrap this up i love you i
love you and i'm happy that i came back
and did this i'm glad you know this sits
on my desk by the way this honeydew cup
this is one of four mugs
i've got
this
who used this before me you everybody
gets a new why would i ever give
somebody a used mug
i don't know what she's up to i don't
know what your producer's up to
sit on my desk yeah i'll send it i'm
going to send that's yours too now you
got a double partner
rogan and marin's podcast mugs with mine
oh you're well yours are your mugs are
much nicer thank you marin's look like
he made it in his shed he's just back
there with him rogan doesn't even know
he had fire
he didn't even know
those are ours gift bags
we giving away tesla's every time
someone does the show that's a tesla
yeah
take a model three dude on your way out
thanks dude
yeah
i gotta go down there haven't been to
austin have you seen tommy and those
guys i've seen him here not down there
so i'm in cancun we linked up in cancun
for that thing that was the last time
i've seen anybody cause those guys all
actually i was in austin
beginning a pandemic to go say hi to joe
and because i was going to dallas but
otherwise everybody left us man
everybody's gone it's all good it's us
we're here well i love you brother i
love you thank you man um plug whatever
tour all over yeah come see me i said at
the beginning come see me go to
anderson.com for the tickets andrew
santino.com come see me otherwise uh
you know that's the only way to see me
that and the bad friends sho podcast and
whiskey ginger i'm not going to be back
on tv until [ __ ] who knows i mean we're
not shooting season three of dave until
july i've watched if we do we might not
even do it really yeah fx i mean
they have to close a deal and dave is
making music so you know they said maybe
the summer but otherwise you know
i'm chilling i did a couple of movies i
did a netflix movie with kevin harden oh
yeah that'll come out i'd said it like
i'm in the movie with him he it's his
movie i'm in obscene in the movie that
still is no it was fun him and mark
wahlberg so anyway go to
andersontino.com buy those tickets come
see me live that's how you want to
indulge in comedy you want to help want
to help the vibe uh come see me live
there it is as always ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media talk to
you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you